[Music]
all right breaking just moments ago we
learned that president trump has
submitted
written answers to the special counsel
robert mueller and the president's
attorney jay sekulow issued this
statement quote
the questions presented dealt with
issues regarding the russia-related
topics of the inquiry
the president responded in writing rudy
giuliani adding quote
it has been our position from the outset
that much of what has been asked raised
serious constitutional issues
and was beyond the scope of a legitimate
inquiry
this remains our position today the
president has nonetheless provided
unprecedented cooperation the special
counsel
has been provided with more than 30
witnesses 1.4 million pages of material
and now the president's written
responses to questions it is time to
bring this inquiry to a conclusion
make no mistake huge win tonight for the
president and his legal team
his attorneys were pushing for written
answers that means no subpoena fight
no subpoena before the grand jury no
in-person interview
no year-long fight headed towards the
u.s supreme court
no perjury traps and keep in mind these
were all
questions none of them were about
obstruction of justice
why because there never was any just
like there was never collusion
instead mueller focused on this russia
collusion
and time and time again the president's
already answered this question
denied any collusion any conspiracy any
coordination
with any foreign government especially
russia
and so now this has just become a
formality now after spending nearly 600
days the investigation might soon
finally be coming to an end
the media hysteria hysteria conspiracy
theories well they'll just find
something new to lie to you about now if
we really care
about truth and equal justice in the
united states today
well tonight the door is wide open
hillary clinton's bought and paid for
dirty russian dossier filled with
russian lies rampant
fisa fraud abuse committed using those
bought and paid for hillary russian lies
literally fraud committed against judges
to get
subpoenas and get warrants against trump
campaign associate carter page
and then after that the coordinated leak
efforts
to literally lie to the american people
propagandize them
misinform them so that that would
influence the 2016 election
that all now needs to be investigated if
we
really care about russia collusion and
equal justice under the law
an equal application of our laws and
tonight the mueller probe
all that seems to be winding down all
the new york times is reporting
that trump wanted to order the
department of justice to prosecute james
comey and hillary clinton
now does that sound like breaking news
to you
because it isn't it shouldn't and
because we know how the president feels
about hillary and comey
and we know hillary committed crimes
it's not even in dispute
and of course the anti-trump haters over
on conspiracy tv msnbc and fake news cnn
acting like they found it they've been
looking for two years and now they've
found it
maybe they could have listened to his
rallies that they wouldn't cover when
they were yelling cnn sucks and lock her
up
they would have learned something there
take a look this is what happens in
authoritarian countries the president
orders the the president the leader
orders the investigation and prosecution
of his political enemies
i think it's prima facie evidence of
abuse and power this
is absolutely off the charts donald
trump is basically
running his office like he's ahead of a
banana republic
i think this is a scandal at 15 on a one
to ten level
he was essentially trying to use the
apparatus
of the state to punish his political
enemies
he never did anything never ever
it's a phony story fake news and when
the story broke by the way we reached
out to greg jarrett for his reaction he
said
how is this even a story he's right
he'll join us later with much more
now during the 2016 campaign then
candidate trump repeatedly said that he
wanted hillary clinton prosecuted
for her email server scandal and clinton
and comey both should have been
investigated we only investigate trump i
guess
in this political climate he gave
hillary clinton the nickname
crooked hillary for a good reason let's
be honest
she should have been prosecuted the
single easiest obstruction of justice
case
slam dunk that i've ever seen in my life
you know when you
delete subpoenaed emails acid wash the
hard drive bleach bit
hammers devices and by the way comey's
actions
legally need to have been looked into
and should be
when we come back also tonight later on
the program we'll have senator graham
joining us he'll weigh in on all of it
now we turn to the situation with saudi
arabia's crown prince
now pay close attention this is going to
be very hard for liberals in the media
to keep up with i want them to pay very
close attention
the murder of the saudi journalist jamal
khashoggi
was reprehensible that is evil
and i have little doubt that this evil
act was carried out
in the saudi consulate in instep bowl at
the direction
of saudi arabia's crown prince known as
mbs
on this program frankly in all the media
well
there's nobody that's been tougher on
saudi arabia
and nobody more consistent of my
criticisms of saudi arabia
for a whole host of reasons i've been
their loudest critic for good reason
i've called out saudi arabia's rampant
human rights abuses
their complete lack of common decency
saudi arabia's treatment of women they
can't drive up to recently couldn't vote
and literally have to ask their husbands
if they may travel abroad
gay people are killed just for being who
they are christians and jews
oh guess what they are literally not
allowed you can't build the temple
you can't build a christian church and
they are persecuted in saudi arabia
and up until recently women in saudi
arabia well
they pretty much couldn't do anything
you know without being around a male
guardian from their family or else they
get in trouble and by the way
women need permission for just about
anything even to marry to work
being gay is illegal punishable by death
christians
and christian churches and temples
banned
now while the clintons were more than
happy to accept tens of millions of
dollars and think about this
the clintons took tens of millions of
dollars to enrich themselves and their
foundation
from the saudi kingdom now what did they
get they've never been this critical of
saudi arabia
as critical as we've been i'll call out
evil wherever i see it the murder of
jamal khashoggi was evil
the world is an ugly dangerous
complicated
place and today president trump he
issued a statement
reaffirming america's strategic
partnership with saudi arabia
and had this to say to reporters at the
white house that they took such umbrage
with take a look
if you look at iran just take a look at
iran and you look at what they're doing
they are a terrorist nation right now
although i must tell you they're a lot
better right now than they were
when i took office when i took off is
they were heading in a very very bad
direction
and at some point things very positive
frankly could happen with iran but we
also need a counterbalance
and israel needs help also if we abandon
saudi arabia it would be a terrible
mistake
president's right and i want to explain
in all specificity why this isn't about
politics as evil
as this kingdom is as i have said over
the years the president is right
saudi arabia has now emerged at an
important point in history
as a partner in the middle east let me
explain this and it brings us to a quick
hannity history lesson
as a country we have to make a lot of
tough
very very difficult strategic decisions
not like putting millions
in your pocket like oh the clintons and
deal with a lot of immoral and even in
some cases evil
international partners i'll give you one
quick example world war
ii we struck alliances with stalin a
mass murderer in russia the former
soviet union
that evil dictator would even go on to
murder more people than adolf hitler
but the survival of america and europe
was in jeopardy
and during the cold war we partnered
with dozens of brutal dictators
to violently squash the spread of the
evils of communism
and now saudi arabia similarly a
horrible regime
but there's a key alliance that is now
in place
and that would be the united states and
israel and egypt and jordan
and also let's see the saudis and the
emirates
and what is the alliance against iranian
hegemony
iran is currently the world's number one
state sponsor or terror
they are funding numerous proxy wars and
if the mueller's the chant death to
america death to israel
and want to wipe israel off the map if
they ever get nuclear weapons
millions and millions of people can die
so we have to make a strategic decision
we can't
take that risk in fact the current
alliance again
the u.s israel jordan egypt the uae the
saudis
has a crucial they've been a crucial
force
in checking this iranian hegemony and
this is the alliance that we now need to
stop these radical muellers
with their radical threats from ever
getting their hands on nuclear weapons
still many on the left they're in
meltdown mode over the president's
handling of saudi arabia
you know what where have they been
former
obama u.s ambassador samantha power
tweeting quote
it is a mean and nasty world but trump's
siding with the meanest and nastiest out
there
whether you know sisi or putin or
assassin mbs will leave the world even
nastier
this statement is a green light for
would-be murderers in countries that
have things
that trump thinks we need um how about a
history listen just for
for you samantha maybe you forgot about
your time in the obama administration
because it was barack hussein obama who
sent
tanks f-16 fighter jets over a billion
dollars to a guy by the name of mohamed
morsi
remember he was with the radical muslim
brotherhood
that rose to power in egypt morsi
the guy that once referred to people in
israel and jews
as the descendants of apes and pigs and
the muslim brotherhood
also funding terror around the world and
by the way
that's your boss former boss obama
who partnered with them for no strategic
reason
obama gifted that guy billions of
dollars
material support planes tanks and cold
hard cash
and we can't forget that yeah obama also
partnered with
the radical islamic muellers in iran the
number one state sponsors of terror
and a horribly flawed nuclear deal the
u.s sent 1.7 billion dollars in cash
and other currency directly to the
muellers yep the same people that plot
the destruction of
israel and the united states on a daily
basis and think god is instructing them
to do it
and treat women and christians and jews
and gays and lesbians the way they do
so susan powers spare us the feigned
phony selective moral outrage and
remember as i pointed out earlier
hillary clinton totally ignored the
saudis treatment
of women gays christians and jews for
millions of dollars in cash because they
bought her silence she's never
criticized the
way we have regularly on this program
so today with iran now posing the single
biggest threat to the united states the
middle east and the world
this strategic partnership with saudi
arabia is too
important if at all possible to
dismantle if we can keep it together
it's smart it's incredibly complicated
incredibly dangerous in the middle east
and on top of that the saudis are
spending hundreds of millions of dollars
on weapons purchases
that by the way both russia and china
wanted
and we got and that means what we're
going to make
let's see putin and the leaders of china
rich again
i don't think that's a good idea and
take americans their jobs away from them
i'm not willing to do that and do we
want to help out
put a new alliance together let's see
the iranians the syrians
china and putin and russia
it's a dark evil ugly world at times far
more complicated than what liberal
networks
that hate donald trump even you know
taking a breath
could ever possibly understand all right
we have to turn to another situation
closer to home
for weeks we have been sounding the
alarm about the massive caravan of
migrants marching toward our southern
border
now we've tracked them through central
america as they broke down guatemala's
border fence stormed into southern
mexico we followed this journey north
towards the u.s
border and warned about possible gang
criminal infiltration
we showed you how the trump
administration prepared for the
approaching caravan
thousands of active duty troops were
sent to the border razor wire was
deployed
to bolster the fencing and new barriers
were also constructed
and hard-working u.s border patrol
agents stepped their
reconnaissance efforts up a serious
situation
but not according to the democrats
remember for a while they were ignoring
the migrant caravan
and accusing republicans of fabricating
this phony crisis
in the lead up to an election for
political gain others called it all a
conspiracy theory obama laughed at the
idea
in one event that he was speaking at no
it's a real situation with real
consequences
we now know our own dhs and leaders in
mexico saying that over
500 criminals and are traveling with the
migrants
and according to a new report law
enforcement has even paid undercover
informants to address security threats
by the way that's called being smart and
yesterday we saw in tijuana authorities
having to arrest 34 members of that
caravan
for offenses like public intoxication
disturbing the peace resisting arrest
but despite all of this a federal judge
yesterday in san francisco what a shock
delta blow to the president's border
security efforts and the rule of law
striking down his temporary asylum ban
on those who don't apply to puerto entry
see why holding the u.s senate and the
president out campaigning
and we picking up seats the first time
in a hundred years a sitting president
that gets the white house is able to do
this in his first midterm election
and as i've been telling you the
majority of people are just searching
for a better life i get that
but we've got to vet anybody that wants
to come here 500 criminals
infiltrated walking with the caravan
people
it's even why mexican people now are
protesting the caravans and saying
they've been invaded
and echoing president trump's tough talk
on the border take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
at donald trump an invasion
oh and our na by the way they're now on
thousands on our southern border
people on the left said they'd never get
there our national security
is about more than just security
unvetted
unchecked mass migration comes at a
massive cost
to you we the people the taxpayer a new
report published in forbes exposing how
you the american people pay for health
care for illegal immigrants to the tune
of
18.5 billion dollars a year and
according to the center for immigration
studies illegal border crossings are up
and comes with it a massive price tag
for the american people
i'll have a lot more on this developing
situation also throughout the show
now tonight the mainstream media is all
but refusing to cover the crisis at the
border but
instead they are busy obsessing over
ivanka trump
she's briefly using a private email
account as it goes back 15 months ago
to send and receive some that were work
related messages
talking about a few hundred emails 15
months ago
she was new on the job new to washington
all the emails have been handed over to
the federal government
um they're saying this is like hillary
although they never criticized hillary
nothing's been deleted a non-story no
classified information
but hillary clinton when she was
conducting state department
apartment business with a private email
and stored
her email private in a bathroom
mom-and-pop shop tech company
many on those emails she sent and
received were deemed top secret she lied
to us
we can prove the lie thousands of emails
were deleted
nobody had ever heard of bleach bit but
now we know what it is
and guess what none of these were turned
over to the federal government
and the media remained silent they
covered for their friend the clintons
and now they're treating ivanka like you
know the non-story like the biggest
scandal of the century what a bunch of
phony hypocrites take a look
the arrogance the incredible arrogance
as with a
little measure of stupidity it's
possible that she's considered a
princess and totally separate from
the rest of the rules that the american
government and the president's
uh cabinet and advisors go by when the
new congress gets sworn in
the house oversight committee
they need to seek nothing less of ivanka
trump and her lawyers and the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth
they really are my family they basically
took what they were doing in the
business the trump organization and
brought it to the white house and didn't
care at all with what the rules were and
what they can and cannot do
yeah they didn't cover hillary's crimes
we know she committed crimes
this is hypocrisy in action this is why
so many americans
don't trust the people in the media nor
should you it's destroyed trump every
second every minute every hour every day
and they're just hypocrites two weeks
ago remember the media ignoring the
story
james comey was using private email for
fbi business
basically crickets you didn't hear the
same type of criticism
and it's the same reason that members of
the media now totally ignoring
their former bff michael avenatti for so
many months he was the poster child
on cable news fake news cnn conspiracy
tv
msnbc spreading vile claims against
justice kavanaugh that they were
spreading and believing they believed
and guess what he's now the left
all of a sudden they they change their
their guilt by accusation
motto the new standard they created in
america yet no one in the mainstream
media all of avenatti's friends
well they're pretty much silent and
pretty much not saying anything so
what does that mean it means the issue
of sexual assault that's so serious
that's not what matters to them because
if it did
they wouldn't be best friends with the
clintons would they they wouldn't have
worshipped the media of been worshipped
by the media as they've been
and keith ellison would have been vetted
and called out
the issue really seems to be important
of sexual assault or charges like this
only if they can bludgeon a republican
then there's no due process then there's
no
presumption of in uh innocence where's
all the outrage on these channels their
best friend
now if you're on the left the rules
don't apply to you one set of justice
for them
and the guillotine pretty much for
everyone else and the mainstream media's
post-election spin doesn't help either
delusional liberals the media they're
now trying to pull a fast one on the
american people saying that trump has
been rejected this has been a massive
blue wave
his presidency has been contained by
some imaginary blue wave
in historical terms it was a trickle
with some democrats refusing to even
call the
election legitimate in races that didn't
go their way we saw that in georgia in
the governor's race
where brian kemp won it won outright but
stacey abrams
said georgia did not have a free and
fair election and kept dismantled
democracy
really classy sounds like sore loserism
the democrats did of course pull out
some victories in the midterms according
to fox's count the democrats they won
232 seats in the house compared to 199
for the republicans four races yet to be
called
they picked up 37 seats for the
democrats but
they lost all those seats and claire
mccaskill's out and height camp's out
and nelson is out and donnelly is out oh
yeah
so president trump if you actually look
at numbers in history
did considerably massively better than
the previous two democratic presidents
2010 obama's first midterm dems lost 63
seats in the house
six seats in the senate 94 bill clinton
lost
52 seats in the house and eight in the
senate
now bear in mind the republicans
actually added to the senate majority
and by the way that number is likely to
grow next week an important election if
you are in mississippi
that special election november 27th
president trump will be stumping for
cindy hyde smith at a rally next monday
as a matter of fact two or three in her
bid to become the first female senator
from the great state of mississippi that
is an important vote if you live there
this is a big race a republican victory
means 53-47 in the senate
and further ensure that trump's agenda
of a booming economy strong national
security
tighter immigration and of course
originalist constitutionalist judges
and the appointments he wants goes
forward